ask anyone who has ever lived in a small
town and they'll most likely I'll tell
you the same exact thing the worst part
isn't just being far away from the
nearest city or distant from friends and
family it's the boredom that gets you
having so little nearby gives you so few
options for things to fill your time
with for some they get used to it as
they grow old spending their life in the
same tiny Community they either learn to
make their own entertainment or just get
used to the boredom drowning It Out by
sitting and watching TV all day but
others they just can't stand being bored
being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do and ultimately they
can end up getting so sick of it that
there's only one option leave pack their
bags and hit the road up sticks and move
to a new place far from the small town
they were born in thing is leaving isn't
cheap moving to a new town own a big
city or even an entirely different state
is a luxury that costs a pretty penny
some might work and save their wages
until they can realize that dream of
moving away but not everyone has that
much patience some Want to Be Free of
the boredom as soon as they can maybe
they might apply to be a contestant on a
game show chance it all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize sure it's a
hell of a Gamble and a loss might mean
humiliation in front of everyone you
know and more but winning could be your
ticket away from small town living that
might be easier said than done though
not only does someone looking to move
away need to be picked as a contestant
they also need to play by the rules and
actually win the game but as if that
wasn't enough they also have to live to
tell about it for as long as she could
remember Kat had always hated it here
her hometown was Tiny too small to
include more than the main street with
few local stores the one school that
everyone who had ever lived there had
studied at and little else of note and
as for things people could do for fun in
the town well as you can probably
imagine the options were severely
limited especially for a group of
teenagers like cat and her friends most
of the time all that she and the others
Leo Ricky and Danny could do to pass the
time was sit in the back of Ricky's
truck and park in the middle of town
watching people and waiting for
something even mildly interesting to
happen not that it ever did the four of
them had a name for the rest of the
townsfolk everyone that had lived there
for their entire lives and never dared
to venture anywhere else lifers as in
they were imprisoned serving a life
sentence in this small town never to
escape or move on or make something of
themselves as much as they like to poke
fun at those people each of the group
knew that every weekend they wasted just
sitting around the closer they were
getting to One Day become lifers
themselves we need to just go cat would
say trying to Rally the other three into
taking a spontaneous trip away as a
group just load up the truck one day
pick a direction and drive until we
fight somewhere Ricky and Leo would nod
their heads in agreement and Danny would
talk for hours all about the places she
might like to go to one day but none of
them ever actually made any plans to
leave nobody knew where to start until
they heard rumors about an abandoned TV
studio just outside of town apparently
according to Danny's older brother it
had been there for years just sitting
there completely empty it wasn't just a
small local Studio either one of the big
National networks had owned it and used
to film there regularly back in the day
why would someone set up a studio here
of all places had been Leo's immediate
response look at where we live cat
replied it's the literal middle of
nowhere the network must have got the
land Dirt Cheap the real question is why
don't we go and check it out what for
Danny asked cats silently gestured at
the cramped Main Street that surrounded
them the place that may as well have
been the center of the known universe to
the four Teenage friends do you see
anything else to do around here before
long the four of them were in agreement
Ricky's truck pulled up in front of
their houses in the middle of the night
and under the cover of Darkness they
drove out towards what was left of the
TV studio this was it they were finally
going somewhere beyond the choking
cramped confines of their tiny Hometown
although whether or not they'd all make
it back was another matter here's a hard
lesson for you kids You Can't Fight For
Life you believe you deserve if you
don't have a little skin in the game
with home a few miles in the rear view
mirror the truck stopped at a chain-link
fence a pair of signs were hanging from
it one welcoming them to the studio
while the other simultaneously on them
to keep out that this area was private
property ignoring it the four of them
stepped out of the truck and started to
climb the fence throwing Leo's jacket
over the top to avoid injury beyond the
fence was a huge building almost the
size of a warehouse with a door marked
Studio entrance that practically invited
the Intrepid teens to open it up and
have a look inside each one of them
carrying a torch in hand the group
walked up to the abandoned studio and
gently pried open the door trying not to
make too much noise even though they
knew the whole place was abandoned they
still didn't want to attract too much
attention and get caught trespassing the
lights were all dead as cat led the
group her hand being tightly squeezed by
Danny next to her the two boys behind
none of them had been sure what to
expect it wasn't exactly like anyone in
the group had ever set foot inside of TV
studio before but they were met with a
narrow concrete walled Corridor so
underwhelming that it almost made it
extraordinary in just help profoundly
dull it was lifting his torch Leo
pointed out some lettering on the wall
that read two tmdg set with an arrow
pointing the four friends further down
the corridor naturally driven by her
curiosity and need to be literally
anywhere apart from her hometown cat
followed the Arrow's direction to
another door pushing it open she stepped
inside her Torchlight immediately being
blocked by a thick curtain rushing her
hand against the material she started
looking for a parting but before she
could welcome contestants
avoid spoon through the dark coming from
somewhere in the space beyond the
curtain instantly Dany screamed at the
sound almost wrenching cat's arm off in
sheer surprise Before We Begin The Voice
continued I need you all to tell me are
you ready cat shot a look back at Ricky
the friend furthest behind her fumbling
with the door they'd entered through it
was locked he couldn't get it to budge
he turned and met cat's gay shaking his
head sure we're ready Leo suddenly piped
up calling out to answer the voice
before the rest of the group could turn
and clear at him the curtain around them
lifted so much bright light came pouring
in that it practically days the four of
them each taking a moment to readjust
when her vision cleared cats saw they
were standing in a huge Sound Stage
blinding spotlights pointing at her and
her friends from somewhere above with
seating area big enough to seat their
Town's entire population in that case
folks you know what time it is came the
voice again talking as if there was a
live studio audience present despite
every chair being unoccupied these four
lucky Challengers will go head to head
each one looking to take home the
victory as well as a huge mystery prize
but only if they dare to take on the
most dangerous game there was a pause as
if this unseen announcer was waiting for
a round of applause without warning more
lights came on Illuminating the space in
front of the four very confused friends
standing before them was what looked
like part of an obstacle course a series
of four horizontal beams over an empty
space the glare of the light was so
intense that even squinting cat couldn't
tell what was beneath it just looked
like a void nothing but total darkness
with four narrow beams Bridging the Gap
between where they stood and another
platform Beyond well what are you all
standing around waiting for the
announcer declared almost mocking the
four teens urging them up
rules of cars there was another awkward
pause like the voice was waiting for
laughter
it's simple the four of you will be
competing to make it through each of our
obstacles make it to the end before our
timer hit zero and you'll be tonight's
big winner but fall behind or cheat and
it's out with you a huge Digital
Countdown illuminated on one side of the
sound stage telling the group they only
had 10 minutes to play cat Leo Dany and
Ricky barely had a chance to question
what was going on exchanging quick
concerned looks before the announcer
started urgently counting them down for
three two one he cheered simultaneously
the four teenagers felt a presence
looming behind them like a figure was
standing just out of view blocking them
from turning back carefully putting one
foot in front of the other cat started
shimmying along the beam in front of her
trying to keep herself steady while also
moving as fast as she could without
falling out of the corner of her eye she
could also see Danny on the beam next to
her doing the same but finding it a
little easier to balance Leo was having
no problem at all sidestepping with
enough speed to keep him practically
neck and neck with cat but Ricky was
wobbling every foot he placed on the
beam he felt like it might give way
beneath him but it was just a game show
right sure it shouldn't even really be
running right now but regardless of why
or how the worst that could happen was
that he would fall his next step missed
the beam entirely and Ricky could feel
himself toppling guys he called out to
his friends trying to shift his weight
onto his back leg cat Danny and Leo all
froze and snapped their heads back to
look at him just in time to see Ricky
Wild Lee flailing his arms his whole
body toppled to one side and he dropped
off the beam with a loud scream not one
of them saw him land or even heard it
for that matter it was as if Ricky had
just been swallowed up whole by the Dark
Void beneath them his scream getting
more and more distant until it couldn't
be heard anymore oh tough break talk
about falling at the first hurdle The
Voice exclaimed as if what had just
happened was some kind of joke so long
Ricky we hardly know you staying
perfectly still but clearly distressed
Danny called out Ricky's name there was
no answer cat just stared wide-eyed at
the abyss below only looking away as she
heard Leo jump the last bit of his beam
onto the platform Danny come on cat
whispered to her friend who looked back
at her with tears streaming down her
face the pair of them carefully stepped
further along their respective beams
trying to stop themselves from looking
down or at the huge clock seconds
ticking away and putting them under even
more undue pressure reaching the other
side Danny dropped to her knees unable
to hold back her sobbing kneeling down
to comforter Kat looked up at the sound
stage's bright lights for any sign of
who was putting them through this bring
Ricky back she
I'm sorry the announcer replied the game
show bravado dropping from their voice
but you agreed to play he'll be fine Leo
said pay you anything he just screamed
like that to scare us Leo you don't
seriously believe that cat asked does
she helped Danny stand up wiping her
friend's tears away is he dead she
sobbed I I don't know cat replied
honestly of course he's not Leo
interjected it's a Sound Stage it's not
like this place is dangerous then why
was it abandoned Danny asked Leo didn't
give her an answer either because he was
distracted by the lights coming up on
the next part of the obstacle course or
because he didn't know and wouldn't
admit it ahead of them was a long
stretch of the course forming a narrow
square-shaped walkway wide portions of
the top side were dropping to the bottom
in regular intervals separating the
tight space before opening it up again
every time the segments lifted up the
three remaining contestants could see
all the way to the other side of the
walkway where a new platform waited for
them with Danny under one arm cat looked
at the far end of the walkway as it
disappeared and reappeared behind the
rising and falling segments then she
noticed the timer the seconds rapidly
ticking down but Leo had noticed it too
and turned to look at the two girls with
a determined expression cat shook her
head at him but it was too late with all
his strength Leo shoved Danny and Cat
both of them Landing flat on their backs
on the platform he bolted towards the
walkway as fast as he could managing to
dodge between each portion pausing as
they came down only to run into the next
one as they lifted back up helping Danny
back to her feet cat ran after Leo he
already had a head start and would
easily make it to the other side of the
walkway before the girls so instead cat
held Danny close and took it slow
methodically waiting for each segment to
lift back up before they went further
into the next safe Zone they were
gaining on Leo who was sprinting to the
Finish between the rise and fall of the
ceiling's crushing weight cat watched
him disappear behind each block only to
see years back when it came back up he
had made it to the platform opposite
panting but otherwise unscathed when she
next lost sight of him that's when the
announcer spoke up again now now Leo Leo
it said that was hardly fair was it and
we all know what happens when you break
the rules as the segment in front of her
and Danny rose again cat caught sight of
Leo just ahead but it was what was
standing behind him that stopped her in
her tracks two huge figures each like a
shadow without anything casting it
towered over Leo one of them reached
forward and grabbed him shrouding him in
a cloak of darkness and he was gone just
like Ricky he vanished cat had been so
transfixed by what she had just
witnessed that she didn't notice where
she was standing right under a block
that was about to drop grabbing her hand
again Denny pulled her out of the path
of the descending slap cat felt it brush
against the back of her leg just as the
pair of them made it out on the other
end and onto the platform the last two
contestants and then there were number
two the announcer cheered pausing again
for a reaction from the empty room we
don't want to play this sick game
anymore Danny yelled well you made it
this far the Unseen host replied time
for our third and final challenge the
final stretch of the course make it
through this and you're home free but
fail Or Break The Rules like Leo and
you'll be disqualified game over it's
okay Danny cat whispered whatever's next
we'll get through it do you think the
boys will come back if we do her friend
asked just like Leo had cat didn't
answer the lights revealed the last
stretch of the course the final platform
was overhead a net climbing wall in
front of them it was a straight vertical
Ascent up with a wall behind the next
and holes in its surface wasting no time
both Kat and Danny started climbing up
the rungs of the thick rump staying
level with each other as they went
higher and then they're off look at them
go ladies and gentlemen the announcer
commented still speaking as if to an
audience but it's not gonna be so easy
the sharp sound of metal made both girls
gasp as long Spike shot forward from the
holes in the wall the blades retracted
fortunately having missed Danny and Cat
this time what had started as a simple
climb up had become something akin to a
twisted game of whack-a-mole with each
of them trying to avoid staying in front
of the holes in the wall for too long
dodging the spikes as they went in and
out they climbed higher and higher until
cat Danny screamed she looked over her
shoulder only to notice she was in the
lead below her Danny was calling up to
her with a fierce freaking expression
her foot was caught in the rigging of
the net kicking and thrashing wildly to
try and free it cat looked back up she
was almost at the platform close enough
to nearly reach it with her fingertips
but behind her her friend was stuck and
with no idea when the spikes would come
next shooting out of the wall Kat threw
herself over the edge of the platform
and landed on her back just as she heard
the gut-wrenching sound of the Spike's
extending ring out she was beside
herself tears streaming down her face it
wasn't uncommon for people to be
overwhelmed to the point of tears at the
end of a game show but Kat wasn't crying
with joy we have a winner
the disembodied voice declared barely
audible to the surviving contestant as
she wept after she'd finished explaining
what had happened to the police a group
of mysterious agents flocked to the
Sound Stage to lock it down stopping
anyone else from getting close to it
they'd found a VHS tape in the mailbox
at the front office of the studio on it
was a recording of a game show a live
audience cheering as one by one Ricky
Leo and Danny failed to complete the
course one of the SCP Foundation agents
had come to interview Kat asking her to
recount the whole story all over again
her account lined up perfectly with
everything seen on the tape then the
agent asked her what her prize had been
after she won a car cat replied the four
of us always wanted to leave home now go
and check out scp-2030 laugh is fun and
scp-1733 season opener for more
televised Tales of Terror and chilling
channels of chaos to keep you glued to
the screen